now a more bad
frankly humiliating embarrassing news
joe biden literally got lectured and
threatened repeatedly by china's
president xi today now it was beyond
pitiful
i was embarrassed for my country
humiliating for the entire country
keep in mind the country's ruling
communist party has a blood lust for our
ally taiwan and now many experts in the
region believe that china is actively
weighing an invasion of their sovereign
island neighbor to me this is not even
in doubt president xi knows that biden
is weak decrepit and that he's not going
to do a thing when they quote have
reconciliation with taiwan when this was
discussed during today's lengthy phone
call china's dictator chi uh he
threatened the u.s he demanded nancy
pelosi cancel an upcoming trip to taiwan
the tyrant exclaimed quote those who
play with fire will be perished by it it
is hoped that the u.s will be cleared
eyed about this in response to this
threat what did your president joey do
or say he did nothing he just sat there
he took it embarrassing the entire
country in fact biden still
you know working to reward china by
ending the tariffs that donald trump put
because they're not they're not involved
with us in free and fair trade so he put
tariffs on china he's still looking the
other way as the deadly you know chinese
fentanyl floods our southern border he's
given the country a free pass on the
virus that was made in that lab in wuhan
he's letting the communist party buy up
land near our military bases buy up our
farmland our ranch land hundreds of
thousands of acres he sent a million
barrels of our oil from our strategic
reserves to china and another four
million to other countries around the
world at a time when we're paying the
highest price we've ever paid for gas
and diesel in our country's history and
now joe is cowering in fear and and took
a lecture and a threat from that
dictator as they threaten our country
joe get a spine
who the hell cares what president xi
thinks
you should have been lecturing him about
the death and horror that china
unleashed on the world about how they
treat minorities in their country you
should have demanded compensation for
the well over one million americans
killed by the virus they try to hide
from the world remember you could you
could fly from wuhan to any other part
of the world but if you're in wuhan you
aren't allowed to fly anywhere into
china and if you're in any other part of
china you aren't allowed to fly to wuhan
i wonder why why didn't you challenge
them joe on their unfair trade policies
of their intellectual property theft
sadly joe biden was a wimp today he
showed nothing but weakness nothing but
appeasement and joe the next time just
hang up the phone if some dictator
threatens you keep the tariffs maybe
double them support taiwan green light
nancy pelosi's trip instead of
capitulation like you showed today make
the communist chinese know that there
will be serious deadly consequences for
any invasion because your weakness is
inviting aggression only peace through
strength works you might want to start
listening to your generals joe if you
can you know focus long enough but if
you refuse to stand up for america and
our allies there will be serious
questions about whether joe biden is
compromised now we do know his son
hunter oh it's interesting why did joe
biden as he was canceling the keystone
xtel pipeline why did he give vladimir
putin a waiver to build the nordstrom 2
pipeline why
is he giving you know lifting tariffs in
china why isn't he holding china
accountable for covet and other issues
and intellectual property theft why is
that could it be because the biden
family syndicate got a 1.5 billion deal
with the bank of china hunter running it
no experience whatsoever in fact the ccp
funded the biden family's lavish
lifestyle for many years uh what did
they get in return how compromised is
the biden family here now with reaction
the co-host of the five gerald rivera
former senior counselor to president
trump kellyanne conway you know geraldo
i know you're a patriot i know you love
your country but you watch today
this president are you not humiliated
and embarrassed how weak our president
was we're getting threatened by him
i wouldn't put up with that for five
seconds and i'll tell you who else
wouldn't have put up with it a guy by
the name of donald j trump he wouldn't
take that crap from anybody
well you know the the problem i think
sean is that i don't know that president
biden knows with our policy is vis-a-vis
china back in may you'll recall he was
asked if he would use military force to
defend taiwan now since the 1970s as you
know since the nixon kissinger days
we've had a policy of one china there's
the chinese government in beijing and
taiwan is part of china now what we've
said is we have strategic ambiguity
we've we've hinted very strongly that if
china were to try to take taiwan by
force the united states would intervene
but now i don't know what our policy is
and that's what the you know the problem
is that that leads to confusion and
confusion leads to peril
now you know the the tenor and and tone
of the remarks i don't know i don't like
communist china i don't trust communist
china i think china is our strategic
rival our principal strategic rival not
russia but china
but uh picking this fight over a nancy
pelosi trip that i don't even know is
real i'm not sure that that's the wisest
thing to do sean
kellyanne i'd love your take on this you
know donald trump as well as i do he'd
never would have put up with that threat
on that call
well he didn't put up with the threats
in fact he took on communist china he
took them on on the uyghurs he the
persecution of the uyghurs in china he
took him on fentanyl i remember in
december first 2018 at the g20 in buenos
aires argentina president trump took on
president xi about scheduling fentanyl
and getting the heck out of our
communities out of our kids bodies guys
it's now the number one killer of 18 to
45 year olds in this country did joe
biden ask president xi about fentanyl
did he hold him to account for the
uyghurs did he hold into account for
stealing our technology is he going to
have this great trade deal that was
enforceable and verifiable and written
with between the trump administration
between the usa and china in january of
2020 before we all
days before we all found out what corona
iris was and what coven 19 would turn
out to be did he talk to him about that
virus
look i think the call today lasted two
hours but the call today actually
started a year ago
when president xi and vladimir putin and
the rest of us in this world saw a
feckless and a reckless
commander-in-chief and president joe
biden withdrawing from afghanistan in
such a chaotic deadly way 13 service
members lost ignoring the advice of his
generals we all saw including she and
putin we all saw women and children
running across that tarmac the man
hanging from the wing of the plane
and turning over control of afghanistan
to the taliban and so when an american
president projects weakness people
property peace and prosperity are
endangered and that's what we all saw
today
you know geraldo i would have liked to
have seen joe biden push back and say
you know what you owe the world
compensation for the deaths because of
the virus created in that lab in your
country and you knew damn well what was
going on there uh i would have preferred
that joe biden say if you don't start
free and fair trade we're going to
double down on our tariffs uh because
we're going to insist that you start
being a fair trading partner i would
have preferred
that
they'd be told in no uncertain terms
what would the price would be for
intellectual property theft and more the
most important thing is
don't you dare tell us
who we're going to send to our ally in
taiwan save your lectures we will send
anybody we want anywhere we want any
time we want and it's none of your
business what we do why didn't he just
say that i can't believe i'm sticking up
for nancy pelosi's right to go
she has an absolute right to go she
needs to understand the consequences
the last time a speaker of the house
went newt gingrich it was 1997 china of
1997 has no
resemblance to the much more powerful
china of 2022 but
no that's my point that's my point we
have the uss ronald reagan there right
now the big carrier strike group 50
ships 27 000 sailors and marines the
united states is not wimping out we we
uh you know when their planes harass
ours we hurry i trust general miller
general joe situation
is the speaker pelosi trip real i though
i haven't heard a memory of her why
doesn't she know
that she and kevin mccarthy will go
together they should i agree with them
because it's a safety issue
it's a safety issue for them look it's a
safety issue for her to really talk
about her whereabouts but i'm very
disappointed that joe biden when the
number three nancy pelosi is being
threatened he talked about climate
change today was she instead about that
look his his administration had to walk
back his comments may and october he
doesn't know what the policy is so the
rest of us don't know what the policy is
i don't even think he could pick it out
on a map that's my opinion but anyway
thank you both hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else